[Music]
[Laughter]
this week show this is from youtuber
mark Rober people were stealing
from his front yard so he created this
crazy bond like device there was a
full-on glitter bomb with some fart
spray Thank You Jillian well this video
is officially well not officially but it
could be sponsored by China gets
possible that's not true don't don't
bring the video into this if you're
doing something that's your own
yeah well I just think I'm the perfect
candidate to live mas at one point 1k
followers on Instagram so it's 1100 oh
one point 100 followers 1,100 close - so
really bad no this is so yummy have you
guys ever gotten revenge on someone who
wronged you like that in sixth grade my
boyfriend dumped me for Megan Reardon
who was way hotter than me and way
better basketball yeah she was like
really hot she had already got her
period it was crazy for Megan even
though make it wasn't even like she
wasn't interested in so I threw ice
cream I said whoa a classic Anna story
ice cream that is a first grade okay you
think this girl already got her period
all day not old enough
it was from the bleachers out of the top
bleacher and he was on the floor and I'd
shot him in the head and so it's like
you could have died and I was like
Leslie swoops this is from marques
Brownlee he's got a great YouTube
channel where he reduced tech stuff he's
always very informative and thoughtful
check it out so he goes through all the
smartphones
does anyone have that phone no no no
because I'm an adult or are we all just
like you know we're in the Apple machine
right but now now really grow have
immersed thread we can't you can't be
changing your life
yeah it's crazy how you get locked into
that like we shamed our director who got
a different you got an on I phone and we
shamed him into getting Idol iPhone yeah
because we're like we don't like that
your texts are green they should be blue
like all of our yeah I do admire it
though I feel like they have more
they're like have a certain integrity
that I laughs the like Android users
yeah I just was messaging with the guy
who sold me my iPhone X today you text
with the employee at the Apple store you
texted a detective that solved your
house crime or whatever yeah the police
officer who likes figured out who was
stealing my packages so I relate to that
first video now you're gonna get
sponsored by yeah yeah that's awesome
you actually befriend corporations
mm-hmm yeah I actually lost a lot of
weight by eating gel
really that's the camera I lost a lot of
weight by eating just pana right now is
eating a delicious chalupa well this is
a Doritos taco from what those are -
Lupe's when did I lose control the show
ended well what's happening why are you
doing this it seems that Jordan lost
lots of weight eating so there you got
you got it folks Jordan is the Jared
Fogel oh you mean yeah oh yeah dude I
love kids
youtuber mr. beast this is a youtube
video where they had $100,000 up for a
prize money yeah and you've got it if
you're the last one to leave the ring
that went like over a day and a half it
was just a bunch of youtubers in a ring
which sounds like it might not be that
captivating but for some reason it's
very compelling they want you're gonna
try too late yeah go go watch the video
I don't wanna spoil it it's on a
youtuber mr. beasts channel do you guys
think that you would do that would you
do what would you do for a hundred
thousand dollars
yeah good question like that I always
think like well I like my life now why
would I do something crazy or like
degrading to get a bunch of money when
it's like I believe in myself i'll just
make i'll just make money regular you
make that much money
well it's like if you listen to those
Tony Robbins tapes Jordan gave me I'm
gonna be honest Tony Robbins not working
dude I'm listening no I wasn't playing
with him look at me I'm living my yolk
era I speak Spanish now I'm on this show
I'm making more money than all of you
their sponsorship okay now this is a
very special video for a couple reasons
that's from Twitter user D underscore
lags la GZ but more importantly its
Jillian our coordinators brother you
want talking to brother this is gone
mega viral hundreds of thousands how do
you feel I am very happy for him but
also very just shocked because it is so
dumb I love him I'm very proud of him
but Twitter you're crazy okay well we
watched a few viral videos you got a
shout out boys Jordan yes okay more box
three says nobody wants this show idea
but I have to pitch it every damn dump
every damn dumb yeah what's that mean I
think it's in reference to us talking
about poop poop stuff yesterday's
unnecessary episode about quite a bit of
dumps now Natasha if you don't mind me
bringing up you have such a monster dump
I think as you put it you break toilets
and so you've been banned from certain
toys another quick story as a kid so I'm
an immigrant I have a lot of immigrant
friends one of my immigrant children
friends her parents bought their first
house in America
my parents and I came over I ruined
their toilet oh yeah I was like you have
just bought a house and I am just on the
party i straight-up ruined their toilet
I instantly clogged it is a ten-year-old
child I don't know what to do I walk out
I lock eyes with the father of this man
who just bought this home and I said
nothing come on next week she's going to
tell you some jokes about the news
stories that happened this week on
cheers to you hi I'm Hannah Dickinson
and this is cheers to you well I'm
kicking off my first round of the
weekend by choosing all the people and
stories that encouraged me to drink
cheers to you MIT researchers for
inventing a method to shrink objects to
nano scale once you shrink everything on
earth your dicks will finally look huge
their dick tastes great cheers to
Millennials who want to sleep with the
Grinch oh and I get because I
the menorah it hits all eight
holes at once take that MIT nerds cheers
to you Dax Shepard for saying Kristen
Bell is the reason you wake up every
morning no dude she's a reason you
even have a bed get up and make her a
sandwich cheers to you chick-fil-a for
beating subway in sales turns out
Americans can tolerate homophobia more
than processed deli meat cheers to you
David Arquette for slamming your trolls
who mocked your wrestling career yeah
those guys don't know what they're
talking about you have so much more to
be embarrassed for did you see his
clothing line awful cheers to you offset
for storming cardi B's performance and
begging her to take you back dude people
weren't cheering you on they were saying
get off the set cheers to you Facebook
for sharing my messages with Netflix and
Spotify wait you're saying three people
read a message of mine it's goddamn
Christmas miracle cheers we should do
whoever leaves this set first at last
that's $100,000
yeah we all have to pay Nate a hundred
thousand
[Music]
you